CALLING FOR MEMBERS OF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE IN
ROOM FOUR FOUR SEVEN SERGEANTS
PLEASE CALL THE MAPS OF MEMBERS
BUT I THINK WE'RE PRETTY CLOSE
TO A QUORUM HERE. I WANT TO
WELCOME YOU ALL. GOVERNMENT
HEARING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AS WE DISPENSED FOR A
VERY SHORT AGENDA OVER THE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE. BEFORE
WE BEGIN TODAY. I'M SURE YOU'VE
NOTICED THAT WERE MISSING
SOMEBODY HERE FROM THE DIET'S
WE ARE SAD TO HAVE LOST DEBBIE
MICHAEL AND I DON'T KNOW IF
SHE'S HERE IN THE AUDIENCE OR
NOT AS A CHEAP. AND I HOPE YOU
WILL ALL- GIVE ROH A HUG AND
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE WORK
SHE'S DONE HERE- IT'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR HER AND HER
FAMILY AS SHE MOVES ON TO WORK
FOR EAST BAY UTILITY DISTRICT
AND SHE'S STARTING THE NEXT
CHAPTER OF HER CAREER- DEBBIE
HAS BEEN. A GREAT ASSET TO THIS
COMMITTEE WE HAVE THERE'S HERE
THAT HAVE BEEN TO TAKE UP THAT
ROLE AS WELL AND WE HAVE FULL
CONFIDENCE WITH THAT BUT FOR
ALL OF YOU HERE IS THAT. DEBBIE
SEC. THANK YOU SO MUCH SO AGAIN
SHE'S IN THE BACK OF THE ROOM
TRYING TO PLAY HI. HIDE. IN IF
YOU WANT TO GO BACK IS THERE.
AND I LIKE TO GIVE A ROUND OF.
A FEW HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS BEFORE
WE GET STARTED. WE HAVE SIX
ITEMS ON THE AGENDA TODAY. OUR
CONSENT KELLER CONSISTS OF ITEM
NUMBER TWO. AB NINE FIFTY THREE
TING AND BLOOM. WE ALSO HAVE
TWO BILLS ON OUR AGENDA FOR
VOTE ONLY I ONE REPEAT THAT
VOTE ONLY. AB NINE NINE TWO
MULLIN AND AB TWELVE SEVENTY
THING BRO WE WILL NOT BE TAKING
TESTIMONY ON THESE BILLS AS WE
HAVE HEARD THESE BILLS LAST
YEAR. AND ENGAGE IN A FULL
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE OF THE
ISSUES AT THAT TIME. ALL OTHER
BILLS WILL BE HEARD IN SIGN IN
ORDER. AND OUR FIRST BILL THIS
AFTERNOON WILL BE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR. AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE
BEFORE WE GET STARTED I THINK
WE BETTER GO IN THAT. BIG ROLE.
AGUIAR-CURRY HERE AT WORK HERE
LACKEY HERE LACKEY HERE BLOOM.
HERE BOERNER HORVATH HERE
BOERNER HORVATH HERE RAMOS
THREE OF US THREE OF US HERE
ROBBIE ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS HERE VOEPEL. OKAY
WE HAVE A DOUBLE SECOR GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAYOS
WELCOME YOU MY FIRST ONE FOR
THIS SESSION AND WE'RE READY A
GREAT AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE.
LOCAL PLANNING BY MAIL JUST TO
SCHOOLS FIRST I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR AND TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR YOUR HELP IN
GETTING THIS AND GETTING THE
LANGUAGE TO THE PLACE WHERE IT
IS TODAY. AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE REQUIRES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE BE
NOTIFIED WHEN A CHANGE IS MADE
TO A LOCAL LAND USE PLAN. THAT
IMPACTS ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ELEMENT. MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
POLLUTING AND HARMFUL LAND USES
THESE DISPARIIES. ARE OFTEN
THE PRODUCT OF PLANNING
PROCESSES THAT PRIORITIZE
COMMERCIAL AND INDUSTRIAL
DEVELOPMENT AHEAD OF
RESIDENTIAL AND NEIGHBORHOOD
QUALITY AND RESIDENTIAL HEALTH.
EARLY LEVEL. EARLY LAST YEAR
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVE YET OF
ETCETERA ANNOUNCER
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE BUREAU OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. THE
MISSION IS TO PROTECT THE
PEOPLE COMMITTEES AND DOOR
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION AND
PUBLIC HEALTH WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IS DOWN- VASQUEZ POLICY
MANAGER WITH SAY HOME
CALIFORNIA BY MIDDLE JUSTICE
ALLIANCE WELCOME. HI THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN MY NAME IS
YEAH ALASKA'S AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
FIVE AND MAKE A REALLY SHORT-
IT'S REALLY SIMPLE WAS REAL AND
REALLY GET OUT HOW DO WE
PROVIDE SUPPORTS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WHEN THEY'RE
IMPLEMENTING THE MM JUST AMEND.
AND WITHIN THE GENERAL PLAN
RIGHT A LITTLE BIT MORE
GUIDANCE AND ALSO TRANSPARENCY
TO THE CITIES AND COUNTIES WHO
ARE OUR TRAINERS HOW DO I- BUT
THE LAW I AM AS IT IS SO WITH
THAT I A PURSE BUCKLEY FOR
ASPIRIN I FELT THANK YOU. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
OTHERS WITH THE- SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE OTHER ANY WITNESSES
COMMITTEE
A MOTION- AND A SECOND WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL I'M GREAT
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD THAT'S GREAT BILL AND I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU. SECOND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY LACKEY NO
BLOOM. BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH
HI BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS
THREE OF US LOSE RIVERSIDE
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVERSIDE
VOEPEL. BILLS UP FIVE ONE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BIGELOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE- ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BONTA WELCOME. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES AND STAFF THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
AB TWELVE SEVENTY SIX WOULD TO
THE LEANUP BILL TO A LOCAL
DISTRICT IN REFORM BILL AB
EIGHT FORTY NINE THAT I
AUTHORED LAST YEAR AND WAS
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR AND IS
CURRENTLY IN LAW AB EIGHT FORTY
NINE IT WHICH WAS REFERRED TO A
FAIR MAPS ACT CODIFIED A NUMBER
OF CRITICALLY IMPORTANT REFORM
TO CALIFORNIA'S WILL BE
DISTRICT PROCESS INCLUDING
REQUIREMENTS FOR TRANSPARENCY
PUBLIC OUR REGION EDUCATION.
AND LOCAL AREA THANK- TO AVOID
GERRYMANDERING THIS IS-
UNCONTROVERSIAL CLEAN UP- IN AB
EIGHT FORTY NINE I HAVE WITH ME
NICOLE WONG UNITY ADVOCATE FOR
THE VOTING RIGHTS PROGRAM AND
ASIAN **** WELL AS JOHN AND
STEIN STAFF ATTORNEY PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR THE VOTING RIGHTS
AND SENSES PROGRAMS THAT. LOCK
AUGUST SECOND SINCE. PRIVATE I
WOULD LIKE TO. HI MY NAME IS
NICOLE LONG AND COMMUNITY
ADVOCATE FOR ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE ASIAN LAW
CAUCUS ON THE VOTING RIGHTS
INCENTIVES TEAM- THIS BILL IS A
STEEP FOR SHIRT FOR CLEAN UP
BILL FOR THE FAIR MAPS ACT AB
EIGHT FOUR NINE WHICH PASSED-
YOUR COMMITTEE LAST YEAR. AB
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX MAKES MINOR
TECHNICAL CHANGES AN OUTBACK
LANGUAGE THAT STAKEHOLDERS
AGREED UPON DURING DRAFTING OF
AB EIGHT FOUR NINE BUT WITH
INADVERTENTLY DELETED FROM THE
BELL- AS ONE EXAMPLE AB TALL
SEVENTY SIX MAKES CLEAR THAT
CHARTER CITIES ARE EXEMPT FROM
FALLING REDISTRICTING CRITERIA
A RANGE REDISTRICTING RIGHT
CRITERIA IF THERE CHARTER
ADDRESSES REDISTRICTING
CRITERIA WHICH IS A COMPROMISE
THAT WAS AGREED TO BY ALL
PARTIES IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE BILL. PLEASE VOTE YES ON AB
TAUGHT ME SIX TO HONOR
COMPROMISED AND THAT ARE FINE
AGES THANK YOU. OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. ONLY HERE TO ANSWER
TECHNICAL LEGAL QUESTIONS GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE LIGHTS
COME UP THE MICROPHONE OF THOSE
IN SUPPORT. YOUR NAME AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION PLEASE. BARBARA
LEE BIRDS ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
KAREN JOHNSON- ON BEHALF OF
LEGAL LIMóN VOTERS A
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE. WE DID GET IN A
MOTION AND WAS OUR SECOND ON
THAT AND THERE WAS A SECOND
RATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. GREAT THANKS FOR BRING
THIS FORD AS WE KNOW SO MANY OF
OUR BILLS WE WORK ON SOMETIMES
IS A LITTLE BIT OF CLEAN UP THE
NEEDS TO BE DONE AND THIS CLOSE
CLOSE THE LOOP SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'LL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR- SUPPORTING A BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
CALLER STAFF. SECRETARY TAKE
THE LITTLE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY VOTERS
LACKEY NOT VOTING BLOOM. BLOOM
HI BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS WAS
RIVAS LOSE RIVERSIDE
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVERSIDE
VOEPEL. THE BILLS OUT FIVE ZERO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE HAVE
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS.
WELCOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH AIR
AND COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE.
WANNA START SAYING I ACCEPTED
THE COMMITMENTS AND HOUSING
THIS MORNING BUT I THINK IT
REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS- AS
YOU ALL KNOW CALIFORNIA'S A
HOUSING PRODUCTION GOAL TO
CREATE ROUGHLY HREE POINT FIVE
MILLION NEW HOMES BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE AND CURRENTLY WE
HAVE PLANS TWO POINT EIGHT
MILLION SO WERE AND THAT'S JUST
WHAT WE HAVE PLANNED THIS I
MEAN WE'RE ACTUALLY. BUILDING
ALL OF THOSE AS YOU KNOW. SO WE
ARE FALLING SHORT OF THAT GOAL.
ONE METHOD INCREASE SUPPLIES
THROUGH SMALL SCALE AND
CRIMINAL A HOUSING POLICY SUCH
AS EASING PRODUCTION PRESSURES
WITHOUT MAKING DRASTIC CHANGES
TO THEY WERE A NEIGHBORHOODS
FABRIC. MODEST MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING LIKE DUPLEXES TRI PLEX
IS QUAD LEX'S- CAN HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
INCREASING SUPPLY IN THIS IS I
THINK. IN CALIFORNIA RECENTLY
USED TO A LOT OF THOSE FORTY
FIFTY SIXTY YEARS GO WE
HAVEN'T AS MUCH BECAUSE- OF
SOME OF THE SINGLE FAMILY
ZONING ISSUES THAT- I KNOW.
MANY OF US A FACE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. FOR EXAMPLE OF LOS
ANGELES- IF 20% OF SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES THAT WERE SOWN FOR
JUST TWO HOMES DUPLEXES. THE
LOCAL HOUSING STOCK WOULD
INCREASE BY SEVEN HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND HOUSING
UNITS. IN SAN FRANCISCO OF JUST
10% OF PARCELS ZONE FOR SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES A COMMENTED TO
UNITS. THERE IS HOUSING STOCK
COULD GROW BY ALMOST 19% OVER
THE NEXT TWENTY YEARS. AB SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE INSURERS MORE LAND
IS ON FOR MULTI FAMILY HOUSING.
AND ABOVE MODERATE AND MODERATE
INCOME COMMUNITIES THAT SORT OF
MISSING MIDDLE MODERATE INCOME
IS VERY KEY. WITH ME TODAY TO
SUPPORT- TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. IS LUIS MANTE
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA EMB. I
ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT- WE HAVE
NO OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WE'VE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH PREVIOUS
OPPOSITION THEY ARE NOT
NEUTRAL- AND WE ALSO HAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THIS
MORNING'S HOUSING COMMITTEE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU AND
WELCOME. MORNING OR AFTERNOON
RATHER MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I
LUIS MANTE WITH CALIFORNIA BE
AYE WE'RE SUPPORTING AB SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE BECAUSE IT'S- BY.
THE WAY TO GO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO. A FOCUS ON ZONING- FOR MORE
MODEST- MIDDLE- A MISSING
MIDDLE HOUSING- THE BILL DOES
NOT CHANGE LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
REQUIREMENTS THROUGH THE
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ALLOCATION PROCESS BUT RATHER
ENCOURAGES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO. ATONE FOR PHIL AS A OF
COME. WITH THEIR STING READ A
HOUSE AT NEED THAT PATIENT. WE
THINK THIS IS GOING TO LEAD TO
MORE INFILL WORK WE THINK IT'S
GOING TO LEAD TO MORE MISSING.
MIDDLE HOUSING WHICH IS ONE OF
THE BEST FORMS OF HOUSING TO
PRODUCE. AND ONE OF THE
CHEAPEST FORMS OF HOUSING TO
RIGHT. NOW SO WE ARE VERY
HAPPY. WORKING WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANKS FOR.
THANK YOU THE OTHER. TWENTY
WITH THE A CALIFORNIA PARDON
ASSOCIATION HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ARE THERE
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT. SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. SEEING NONE WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE YES. I KNEW IT WAS
GONNA BE TASHA. QUESTION. SO I
HAD A COUPLE CLARIFYING
QUESTIONS ON THAT CAN A COUPLE
HARDER QUESTIONS SO WHEN THIS
IS GOING TO AFFECT. JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. SO IF I'M
NOT MISTAKEN THE NEXT ROUND
AROUND OF HOUSING ELEMENT
UPDATES ARE DOING APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IS THAT CORRECT. I
COULD WRITE ABOUT TWENTY TWENTY
ONE SORRY IF IT'S ABLE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE CITIES LIKE MINE
HAVE TO GO TO VOTE OF THE
PEOPLE. SO ASKING CITIES AND
GIVING THEM ONLY THREE MONTHS
TO POTENTIALLY REVISED A
PUBLICALLY VETTED PLAN TO
ACCOUNT FOR THIS BILL GOING
INTO EFFECT IN JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IS AN
UNREASONABLE BURDEN I THINK ON
MANY LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WHO
MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE WANT TO
EMBRACE THE CPO. AND SO ONE OF
THE THINGS I THINK YOU SHOULD
CONSIDER IS CHANGING THE
EFFECTIVE DATE SO IT DOESN'T
AFFECT THE NEW RENO CYCLE THAT
IS. I'M SURE IT'S APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WHEN THOSE HAVE TO
BE SUBMITTED- BECAUSE IT IS
ONLY MORE TIME THEY'RE DOING
WE'RE DOING OUT WHICH ALREADY
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CYCE. AND ALL OF MY CITIES IN
MY JURISDICTION AND SO ADDING
THIS AFTER THE FACT WILL BE
WILL BE A VERY UNDUE BURDEN AND
SO IF THAT'S SOMETHING I THINK
YOU SHOULD CONSIDER CORRECTING
BEFORE IT WOULD COME TO A FLOOR
VOTE TICKETS OUT OF COMMITTEE
TODAY- COULD YOU DEFINE WHAT
METROPOLITAN JURISDICTION MEANS
I KNOW WHERE THE IMMENSELY
TOOK. THIS IS TAKE OUT THE
BERMAN JURISDICTIONS BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING FROM HOSPITALS
USING CENSUS TRACT DOESN'T
ACTUALLY EXCLUDE WHAT WE WOULD
CONSIDER NECESSARILY BERMAN
COULD YOU SPECIFY WHERE EXACTLY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THIS
WOULD APPLY. SURE METROPOLITAN
CITIES OUR POPULATIONS OF
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND- INCLUDE
ING ALAMEDA COUNTIES ALAMEDA
CONTRA COSTA ELDORADO LOS
ANGELES BRAND. OF ORANGE COUNTY
PLASTER THE RIVERSIDE.
SACRAMENTO SAMBAR DID INTEND TO
GO SAN FRANCISCO CEMETERY
YELLOW. SO IT'S METROPOLITAN
AREAS ARE CONSIDERED BY
COUNTIES. THAT'S CORRECT. OKAY
SO I DON'T THINK WE'RE REALLY
GETTING AT THE CORE OF WHAT
MOST PEOPLE CONSIDER
METROPOLITAN I THINK THERE'S
SOME AREAS THAT WANT TO BE VERY
URBAN AND SOME AREAS THAT WANT
TO BE SUBURBAN AND I THINK THIS
BILL WOULD UNDULY OVERTAKE
LOCAL CONTROL AND I WANT TO
POINT OUT AND IN MY CITY AND MY
CITY ANTHONY THIS IS A VERY
DIFFICULT HOUSING CITY- AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT ARE SPECIFIC PLANS. IN OUR
ELEVEN TO OUR EIGHTEEN THERE
ARE SOME PLACES WHERE WE
ALLOWED DUPLEXES BY RIGHT SEC
EVEN IN DIFFICULT PLEASE THERE
ARE PLACES THAT ARE ZONING FOR
DUPLEXES ALREADY AND SO I WOULD
WONDER WHAT IS YOUR LOGIC WHY
WE NEED THIS BILLS WHEN IT'S
COMPLETELY WITHIN LOCAL CONTROL
POWER. TO DO THIS ALREADY.
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT MANY CITIES
ARE NOT IF MY CITIES DOING IT
LOTS OF CITIES CAN DO IT I HAVE
TO BE FRANK. I CAN ANSWER A
LITTLE BIT IN A LITTLE BIT MORE
DETAIL ON THAT- THE STATE'S.
HOUSING ELEMENT LAW CURRENTLY
GIVES- LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THREE
YEARS TO COMPLY TO UPDATE THEIR
ZONING CODES- TO MATCH WHAT THE
REGION- ALLOCATES TO THEM
THROUGH THE EXISTING PROCESS.
THIS BILL DOESN'T CHANGE ANY OF
THAT- WHAT IT DOES CHANGE IS IT
ESTABLISHES A- VERY MODEST
DENSITY STANDARDS FOR. THE
MODERATE AND ABOVE MOD
CATEGORIES I WHICH CITIES LIKE%
YOURS RT COMPLY FOR THE LOW END
VERY LOW. ON THE VET LOW IN
VERY LOW ALLOCATIONS THAT THEY
RECEIVE FROM THEIR WE DON'T ALL
COMPLY WITH LOW AND VERY LOW
BUT YES WELL THEY THEY DO
UPDATE THEIR SITES INVENTORIES
TO IT YOU OTHERWISE YOU DON'T
HAVE A- A COMPLIANT HOUSING
ELEMENT THREE TD. AND WHILE
CITIES AROUND THE STATE ARE
NOT. MEETING THEIR RINA TARGETS
IN MANY OF THESE PLACES
ESPECIALLY ACTUALLY IN THE MOD
CATEGORY IN THE MODERATE
CATEGORY- LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE TO UPDATE THEIR SITES
INVENTORIES AND ALL DO. MOST OF
THEM SO WHAT BUT WHAT I'M
SEEING IS THERE'S NO
JURISDICTION IN MY DISTRICT.
THAT ACTUALLY HAS INSUFFICIENT.
ABOVE MODERATE CATEGORIES. ALL
OF THEM ARE SUFFICIENTLY
PLANNING FOR THEIR MODERATE
CATEGORIES AND I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE IN
SACRAMENTO. SIT HERE REMEMBER
THAT CITIES ARE THAT THE
CONTRACT THAT WE IS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAVE WITH OUR
CITIES. IS THAT THEY PLAN FOR
IT THEY'RE NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR
BUILDING IT SO WHEN WE LOOK AT
WHAT'S BEING BUILT AND WHAT'S
BEING. PLANNED FOR THE CITY IS
A RESPONSIBLE FOR PLANNING. AND
SO WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS I THINK
THERE'S A REALLY. THE BIGGEST
ISSUE I THINK ISN'T WORKING.
AND IT FROM SACRAMENTO OF
SOMETHING THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN ALREADY DO BY
THEMSELVES. THAT THEY'RE IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH EACH CD
ABOUT ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE
SUFFICIENT MODERATE AND ABOVE
MODERATE SITES. ALL CITIES IN
MY JURISDICTION DO. AND WE
DON'T HAVE A GAP THERE. AND IT
IS A CITY HAS A GAP IN PLANNING
FOR MODERATE AND A- MODERATE
ABOVE MOTOR. THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENT I'M SORRY. THERE
HOUSING ELEMENT WILL NOT BE
APPROVED. SO I THINK IF ONE
WERE TO INCENTIVIZE THIS THAT'S
FINE IF THE HOUSING IS THAT HE
DIDN'T PLAN FOR THIS THAT'S
FINE. BUT IT SHOULD BE ALREADY
REQUIRES THAT THEY'RE
SUFFICIENT MODERATE AND ABOVE
MODERATE AND HOW IS CITY DOES
THAT ARE JURISDICTION DOES THAT
IS UP TO THEM. IT'S NOT UP TO
US TO TELL THEM THEY HAVE TO
GET RID OF OUR ONE ZONING. I
THINK I THINK I THINK THIS BILL
WOULDN'T WOULDN'T DO THAT I
WOULD JUST REQUIRE THAT FOR
THAT SITE THAT THEY IDENTIFIED
TO MEET THEIR MODERN ABOVE MY
NEEDS. 25% OF THOSE WOULD HAVE
TO ALLOW AT LEAST DUPLEXES SO
IN. THE CASE THAT YU'RE
BRINGING UP IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
ANTHONY THIS IS ALREADY
COMPLYING WITH THAT. THAT MIGHT
BE THE ONLY CASE FOR INSIDIOUS
MAY COMPLY WITH NOT- IS
SUPPOSED TO LAUGH BECAUSE-
CLEARLY DON'T KNOW MY CITY
THANK YOU- I JUST THINK IT'S- I
THINK IT'S AN- OVER REACH ON
OUR PART AND I WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING THIS- I THINK CITIES
ARE PERFECTLY WELL WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS DECIDE. HOW THEY
WANT TO REACH MODERN ABOVE
MONGOLS AND THAT'S WITH THE
NEGOTIATION BETWEEN CITY IN
EACH CITY. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS I HAVE A QUESTION
SURE MY READING OF THIS IS THAT
THERE IS FLEXIBILITY WITHIN THE
BILL BURR CITIES AS WELL AS AN
OFFRAMP ON THIS IS THAT IN MY
RIGHT WE VIEW THIS AS VERY
FLEXIBLE WE'RE NOT DICTATING
WHERE EVERYTHING ELSE TO GO WE
JUST WANT 25% TO BE AVAILABLE
FOR MULTI FAMILY HOUSING IT
DOESN'T REQUIRE IT. OKAY THAT'S
WHAT I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
BECAUSE THEY DON'T GET THINK
THERE WOULDN'T MAY MAYBE- MY
SKULL THE OF NEW THAT BUT I
JUST THINK THAT THERE'S SOME
FLEXIBILITY IN THE BILL AS WELL
SO I JUST WANTED TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT ALRIGHT ARE THERE ANY
OTHER. WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ALREADY SO DENY AND THERE OKAY
WE ASK QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
THE BILL RIGHT AND THE SECOND
OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECT ASPIRIN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH US SECRETARY
CULTURAL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY HI
LACKEY NO LACKEY NO BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BOERNER HORVATH NO
BOERNER HORVATH NO RAMOS
THREE OF US. THREE OF US SIDE
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVERSIDE
VOEPEL. VOEPEL NOW THE BILL. WE
NEED BILL NEEDS ONE MORE VOTE
DO WE HAVE A IT'S A RESILIENT.
OKAY SO WE'RE WAITING FOR ONE
OF OUR OTHER CALLING SCOUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FIRST WE WILL DO OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR WELL WE HAVE A MOMENT
HERE SO- WE HAVE A MOTION FOR A
CONSENT. CONCERT CALENDAR.
QUESTION. THIS RIVAS IS MOTION.
OKAY AND THE SECOND WELL THANK
YOU. AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY
I LACKEY. CONSENT OR YES HI
LACKEY AYE BLOOM BLOOM I
BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS
THREE OF US THIS RIVERSIDE
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVERSIDE
VOEPEL. HELLO MY. OKAY WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO OUR TWO BILLS
THAT ARE VOTE ONLY WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH AB NINE NINE TWO
MR MULLIN AND I- I JUST WANT TO
DO A BRIEF REMINDER AB NINE
NINE TWO IS BEING BROUGHT UP
TODAY ON RECONSIDERATION FOR A
BOAT ONLY AS WE HEARD THIS BILL
LAST SPRING AND THOROUGHLY
DEBATED THE ISSUES AT THAT
TIME. AS A REMINDER AB NINE
NINE TWO AS A NEW X. EXCEPTION
TO THE BROWN ACTS GENERAL
PROHIBITION AGAINST SERIAL
COMMUNICATIONS WHEN A MAJORITY
OF LOCAL GOVERNING BODIES
MEMBERS ARE USING SOCIAL MEDIA
SIMILAR TO THE LAST SPRING
SPRING I WILL NOT BE MAKING A
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS BILL. I
NEED- ENTERTAIN A MOTION. ON.
SECRETARY CALLED ROLE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AGUIAR-CURRY
NO AGUIAR-CURRY NO LACKEY.
LACKEY NO BLOOM. BLOOM I
BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS
THREE OF US THREE OF US SIDE
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVERSIDE
VOEPEL. VOEPEL NOW IN THE BILL
STILL NEEDS ONE VOTE THANK YOU
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO AGAIN
ANOTHER VOTE ONLY ON AB TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE BRO. AS A
REMINDER. AB TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE IS BEING BROUGHT UP TODAY
FOR VOTE ONLY AS WE HEARD THE
BILL LAST SPRING ENGAGED IN A
LENGTHY DISCUSSION OF THE
ISSUES AT THAT TIME AS A REMAKE
A REMINDER AB TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE WOULD LIMIT THE AUTHORITY
OF THE TRANSPORTATION QUARTER
AGENCY IN ORANGE COUNTY. MANY
DIFFERENT AGENCIES MAKE UP AND
GOVERN GOVERNED TCA.
UNFORTUNATELY NOT EVERY
DECISION BEING MADE IS GOING TO
BE POPULAR WITH EACH MEMBER
AGENCY. BUT THAT BEING SAID T.
C. A. WAS CREATED LOCALLY. AND
I BELIEVE THAT THE ISSUES- THIS
BILL ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS OUR
BETTER SOLVED AT A LOCAL LEVEL.
WELL I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUES COMMITMENT TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF THE
RESIDENTS OF THIS CAN BE A
COMMUNITY I AM ABLE TO SUPPORT
BILL TODAY. SECRETARY TAKE THE
ROLE. I WOULD IMAGINE. I NEED A
CHAMBER SHOULD MOVE IT. WHERE
IS IT. WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY NO LACKEY NOT
VOTING LACKEY NOT VOTING BLOOM.
BLOOM NOT VOTING
BOERNER HORVATH NO
BOERNER HORVATH NO RAMOS
THREE OF US. THREE OF US NOT
VOTING ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS NOW VOEPEL SO USED
ABILITY NO I'M GOING. VOEPEL I.
YEAH SIMPLE AND. THE BILL DID
NOT GET OUT. WHEN WE WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ANOTHER FIVE
MINUTES ACTUALLY BEEN. THE
SERVER ONLY MISSING ONE
PERSON'S SO CAN WE CALL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALMOST PLEASE.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
ATTENTION TODAY APPRECIATED AND
EVERY STILL TRYING TO HIDE.
YEAH YEAH. THE TERM. YEAH. FOR
CALLING FOR THE WELL. I'M SORRY
PLUS
. YEAH EVERY. YEAH. YEAH
YEAH. OKAY FOR ONE YEAR LET'S
SEE IF THE- WELL. THE. WELL I.
NOT OVER A HUNDRED FOR THESE.
THAT YEAH. YOU HAVE A COUPLE WE
NEED YOU TO VOTE ON OKAY. YEAH
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX BONTA SAID TO PASS
VOEPEL UPSTATE. THE VOEPEL OF
STAINED. AND ITEM NUMBER FOUR
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS VOEPEL
NO VOEPEL NOW. ALRIGHT OKAY
SAID IN FOR ME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLYMEMBERS. THANK
YOU. FOR SOME OF THE MONTH. BUT
WAIT A MINUTE HERE. THIS IS NO
B. AS YOU DO A VERY GOOD JOB OF
THIS COMMITTEE THAT SHOULD BE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED FROM.
ANOTHER MAYBE THE US IN THE
FUTURE RIGHT. YOU KNOW. YEAH
YEAH YEAH RELATED NEVER
GENERALLY. YOU GO TO. OKAY.
YEAH. YEAH YOU KNOW A NUMBER OF
THE PERSON WE NEED. SO. YOUR
BOOK ABOUT. WELL YEAH YEAH YOUR
BOOK OF MINE IS MINE THANK YOU
SO. SO LET'S. LOOK. THE
CURRENT. THAT FLOWS. THAT. IS A.
MOTIONS. LAST YEAH. OKAY YEAH.
AND IT WAS DARK AND. HAPPY
ABOUT. YEAH THE SECOND YEAH.
AND. THANK YOU. YEAH YEAH YEAH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. YEAH YEAH YEAH
AND- YEAH. AB I. YEAH YEAH.
YEAH YOU PROBABLY. IN YEAH.
YEAH YEAH. THE YEAH THE- YEAH.
AND. LIVE IN WHICH WE OF THE.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE. MOST RECENT
YEAH YEAH YEAH YEAH. YEAH BUT-
THAT SHOULD. YEAH. YEAH
. YEAH.
IT DOESN'T. BUT I WAS WORKING
WITH THE STATE. YEAH YEAH OKAY.
RIGHT I JUST. THIS IS A. HAVE A.
OKAY THANK. YEAH. THE BILL HAS
A
. AND. YEAH. A LOT OF WAS ONE.
YEAH YEAH YEAH. THIS IS ONE OF
THE- YEAH. AND. YEAH. YEAH.
YEAH LIKE I MIGHT. BE ABLE TO
DO THAT AGAIN. SO HIGHER UP YOU
KNOW WHAT I MEAN. THAT WE'RE
GOING TO. PROJECT OR IF I IN.
YEAH BECAUSE YEAH. DONE YEAH.
WE HAVE. SENATE AND- SO ON.
YEAH YEAH YEAH. YEAH YEAH AND-
I. WHAT'S GOING ON HOUSING. IN
A. YEAH BECAUSE OKAY. ROLL.
YEAH REYES. LARA. YEAH BACK TO
THE. YES. YEAH. RIGHT YEAH.
THAT THE. YEAH YEAH. WHAT YOU
GONNA DO ABOUT. THE THIS IS THE.
SIX NINE. YEAH YEAH YEAH. YEAH.
YOUR STAFF FOR TRAVELERS YEAH.
SENATOR SAID. THE WAY YOU
SHOWED UP. BATTLES. OKAY WAY TO
GO BACK TO ADD ONS. ITEM ONE AB
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE WITH SIX
RAMOS. RAMOS SIGH. ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB NINE FIVE THREE TANG
CONSENT RAMOS RAMESSIDE. ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX BONTA RAMOS. FROM A SIGN.
ADAM FOR AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE RADIUS RAMOS. RAMOS I. AB
FOR AT ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB NINE
NINE TWO MULLIN RAMOS. RAMOS I
ITEM NUMBER SIX. AB TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE BRO RAMOS RAMOS
SNOW. KATIE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLYMEMBER. AB SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE IS OUT. A VOTE IS
FIVE THREE. TWO ONE. UHHUH ITEM
NUMBER SIX WHEN. ONE TO FOUR SO
DID NOT MAKE IT OUT RIGHT IT
FELT PASSAGE. I THINK THAT'S
THE- OKAY THANK YOU. HEARING IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU ALL